cam newton has had his development at
least in new england slowed down this
year by his covet diagnosis he was on
weei's greg hill show earlier today here
he is when he was asked if he has
interest in staying with the patriots
beyond the expiration of his contract at
the conclusion of this season
i don't know if you've had a chance to
think about it yet but do you
do you have interest in being a patriot
in 2021
man i had interest in in winning the
arizona cardinals game how about that
i mean
there's so many things that
that
i mean i i don't want to even
harp or dwell or even think i think my
my as the bible says my compass runneth
over us you know with
just trying to focus on
you know the the near future rather than
the far future
it's a lot of f's there kapith runneth
over it i don't think that's quite the
quote but it's close enough shireen i
guess when in doubt just add a th to the
end of every word in the quote but look
this isn't quite a situation where
anything other than a yes is a no but it
is curious that he wouldn't say i love
it here and i want to stay here and
we'll see how it goes if they'll have me
i'd like to be here it it and and part
of its negotiating ploy and with bill
belichick you always have to be aware of
that one of the theories that chris hims
has this year is bill belichick is
intentionally holding back jc jackson he
wasn't on the pro bowl ballot he's
technically not a starter because they
don't have to pay him a ton of money so
that's part of this but i was a little
surprised that it wasn't more of a
yeah i like it here and we're trying to
build something that really didn't come
across
no it didn't mike and he's on a one-year
deal and you look at what he's done this
season four touchdowns seven
interceptions his passer rating is 27th
in the nfl and you wonder who is going
to give him a chance if it's not the
patriots who gives him a chance and i
don't know the answer to that because
when when the panthers cut him in march
it was all the off season until the end
when the patriots finally gave him a
chance and you know you do wonder who is
going to sign him if it's not the
patriots next year and you also wonder
is it time for the patriots to play
jared stidham to see what they have in
him to see if they need to go address
the quarterback position he was supposed
to be the guy coming to the year before
they signed cam newton
and he hasn't done it he hasn't gotten
too much of a chance maybe it's time to
go play jared stidham and see what you
have in him and just make sure you don't
have something in him you didn't know
that you need to go find a quarterback
in the off season
something the new england patriots
haven't done since the 2000 season when
they finished 5 and 11 playing out the
string and having strategic objectives
unrelated to making it to the playoffs
and getting the highest possible seed
weird times indeed for the patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports